regi Aloysius Miller who joins us on the
program and as he does every week this
week he's got the cabs at the Raptors on
Thursday night at 8:00 Eastern on TNT
reg did you watch the national title
game well before you get to that isn't
that almost a no-brainer you would I
would assume most people would take Bill
Belichick right whose career would you
rather have between Belichick and Saban
I would assume you would go with
Belichick right because winning five
Super Bowls that's the pinnacle right
we've seen Nick statement at the pro
level and it wasn't very good in Miami
correct yeah
but he's gonna be probably the greatest
college football coach of all time and
there's no baggage that goes along with
his college coaching career where's
Belichick is gonna have controversy
attached to his pro career and you got
to share that with Tom Brady because of
Spygate yeah you know I'm gonna guess
with that and the fact that you know
people are gonna go well is it more
about Brady or is there more about
Belichick nobody's saying that with Nick
Saban five Super Bowls okay
six national titles the pinnacle the
pinnacle of professional football right
is to get to a Super Bowl I just throw
it out there
I just think don't yell at me just don't
don't give me don't get me wrong because
to me when I look at Nick Saban most
people think of hit think of Bill
Belichick because people hate on Bill
Belichick and people hate on Nick Saban
it's because they're champions they're
winners but don't you think Saban is
sort of like Christian Laettner like an
unbelievable college career but you know
was okay in the pros I think I would put
Bill Belichick Joe Jackson Nick Saban
John Wooden coaching hey guys the coach
K they are red auerbach they were ahead
of their time and makes it you know to
catch bear come on now that's that's a
heck of an accomplishment though those
those coaches
they they are ahead of the game in my
opinion did you watch the game last
night I did did you think it was a great
game or a great finish great finish yeah
first half I almost turned it off as
like okay I'll just watch the highlight
but then when they made the quarter bad
things I was like okay this is gonna be
either a great story or this is not
going to end well but it isn't it
fantastic but can you imagine being a
freshman in a situation where you're not
even starting freshman yeah no a true
freshman and not a lot of snaps right
how many snaps did he have all season
because jaylen hurt was understand ER
right yeah there were no meaningful
snaps that he took they were all like
mop-up snaps and listening to savings
comments postgame he said that he felt
that he was gonna have to throw the
football in this game so did he get
extra snaps during this week's practice
leading up to potentially coming in or
did he just wing it and say hey I know I
got a gunslinger as a quarterback a true
freshman let's roll the dice but again
that's why I say Nick Saban is ahead of
the game
he's Reggie Miller NBA on TNT Cavs at
the Raptors coming up on Thursday night
what do you expect from the Cavs on
Thursday considering what happened last
night against Minnesota oh it well
certainly I hope it's about bounce-back
game and again I don't want to you know
be too cognizance you got to understand
it's one game but they have not played
their best over the last three weeks
remember they had that 14 or 15 game
winning streak and they had climbed back
into the Eastern Conference race but for
whatever reason now the defense
continues to go south when that was the
strong suit during that winning streak
so it's one game I'm not going to get
too high too low for getting beat down
by Minnesota in Minnesota because
Minnesota is a pretty good team with
young talent but this is a chance for
you to make a statement against Toronto
who no one is talking about in the
league and especially in the Eastern
Conference it's either Cleveland or
Boston but you've forgotten that Toronto
has the second best record and DeMar
DeRozan is playing out
his mind right now so hopefully it is a
bounce-back game for the Cavaliers
here's LeBron after last night's game
and the reporter is asking him about his
plus/minus you could say it was the
worst in terms of plus/minus I won a
game ahead of that plus/minus before so
what does that matter don't give a damn
about no damn plus/minus yeah I probably
the plus/minus not the way to attack
LeBron in animation no no no and
truthfully players they really don't pay
attention to plus/minus I don't know who
came up with that it's really when wins
or losses because he's absolutely right
when I played I had great games when
there was plus minuses and we won and
I've had a plus/minus that was great and
we got beat by 15 so it really doesn't
matter in the days about winter long
explain to me if you're Luke Walton how
do you approach the team after what
lebar ball said about these these kids
don't want to play for Luke Walton your
your thoughts when you heard that and I
know that Kyle Kuzma had stood up for
his coach
Lonzo didn't exactly say it I'll play
for anybody here but here we have more
drama
and I don't know if this is a situation
where Magic Johnson gets back involved
in it
just to say let your son just play and
let Luke Walton coach what do you make
of this situation in those comments well
number one you know you and I we've
tried to stay away from loved our ball
on this show because you know I don't
like giving him a platform but he's made
it impossible not to do so so I hope
he's enjoying his European vacation and
his sons are enjoying playing over in
Lithuania because those two in my
opinion have no shot of playing in NBA
and if he continues to open his mouth
all three of those boys are gonna be
playing overseas because no coach
general manager or owner are gonna want
to put up with the dad and I've always
said that pops is putting his kids at a
disadvantage by continuing to open this
mountain he thinks it's great for
business and selling shoes but it's not
and if you're Luke Walton I would have
Oh
long conversation with Alonzo number one
and this is a time for Magic Johnson the
greatest Laker in my opinion of all time
and now has taken the helm back to run
the Lakers this is a chance for Magic
Johnson to axe to absolutely put his
foot down and put it into this because
he could really destroy Lavar if you
really wanted to and I would I would
come close to almost threatening if you
keep opening your mouth we're gonna
trade your son we are going to trade
your son from the Lakers so it's one of
the two things shut up all in line that
Luke do what he's got to do and let
Lonzo play well how long don't wants to
play or we'll start taking calls Magic
Johnson
the Magic Johnson has to say that yeah
not Luke
not Luke we have to coach the team he
has to be diplomatic and he has to yes
the coach but this is a chance for Magic
Johnson to be like yes you gotta shut up
dude
I don't know who you think you are you
gotta shut up yeah it's unfortunate
because you can tell Lonzo doesn't play
with a lot of confidence and I think
it's because he feels the weight of the
world and then you add this to it
because the first thing I thought when I
saw these comments and you're right I
don't like giving him a platform I would
love to just see the kid play and be
allowed to play without his dad
blabbering but I also look at it and go
did did Lonzo tell levar ball this did
like how does he know that they don't
want to play for Luke Walton that would
have been the first question I asked now
all of a sudden
Lonzo could be the source on this and it
puts him in it in a tough situation here
and I don't think his dad gets that and
if you are Alonso to when the microphone
is stuck in your face you've got to say
kind of take the colic who's in the
route yeah this is my guy and I'm
rolling with him you can't say I can
play for anybody because you're opening
up Pandora's Box like follow-up
questions like well sure you can play
for anyone but can you play police we
know that we can you believe
it's unfortunate because I think Lucas
is a great young coach he's a perfect
fit
obviously he's won championships for
that organization and it's uncalled for
like where where's levorg getting this
information from unless it's cover from
his son I know if it's coming from his
son then that's a different story a
different discussion and that's when I'm
talking about Magic Johnson has to step
in here because we have a snitch in the
locker room I know that one I know that
got a snitch in the locker room and and
you've got to address that that's the
one that's the one thing you cannot have
on a 15 man team is a snitch I don't
care how good it's going or how bad is
going you can never have a snitch in the
locker room great stuff reg safe travels
up to Toronto I love Toronto let me in
the city oh the city I love Tron lean do
you I call it a clean New York baby have
fun and safe travels I appreciate it
thank you brother
that's a Reggie Miller for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]